don't panic see thank you for the
present and she said I believe I shall
[Music]
fish
we have
[Music]
okay okay you may go
okay here's Terence Mckenna Terence
explain what it is that they're looking
at here this is the monument to the
departure point of the great Portuguese
navigators luring Africa girdles the
world in the superior technology of the
astrolabe that was what gave them the
edge Robert is done Milton Robert you
wanna make a statement
oh um hi hi say hi to dinner hi Dennis
never
[Music]
after chaos me
Terrence's the shaman's fell to the
necks and the Neuromancer
nice of the style I got a Greco Christ
well there was a young couch show named
Bruno instead about sex there is one
thing I do know women are fine and boys
are fine but the iguana is numero uno
you know these people are not
pretentious they are perfect your eyes
that's a naturally what does it actually
do it allows
here we are Lisbon
smoking a hash cigarette
they say maybe it's just handled tonight
you never know no no everybody for the
afternoon
the easiest job ever healthy
that talk for an hour advantage of
questions for now
yeah don't I usually just have
scientific lectures
shooting outside today
[Music]
Oh
the street has told what URL booster
sweet for the novel
novelty